ich stehe heute vor einem typischen haus
in berlin
wir besuchen jetzt helge das ist typisch
für einen hauseingang in deutschland es
gibt eine klingel viele klingeln und
eine gegensprechanlage
ich dringe bei helge das ist der
hausflur
das ist ein typischer hausflur vor allem
haus in berlin
es ist ein altbau haus das heißt es ist
in einem bestimmten alten stil gebaut
ungefähr 100 jahre alt und die decken
sind sehr hoch
dieses haus hat fünf stockwerke ich gehe
die treppe hoch gott sei dank gibt es
hier einen aufzug
ich hole den aufzug der aufzug ist schon
da ich gehe in den aufzug
jetzt fahren wir in den fünften stock
da ist helga hallo wie geht's euch gut
schön dass wir dich besuchen dürfen ja
kommt herein
okay ich gehe in die wohnung
ich ziehe meine schuhe aus das macht man
in vielen deutschen wohnungen
wir sind zu hause bei helga hengge
zeigst du uns die wohnung sehr gerne
was würdest du gerne singen alles das
kriegen wir hin
helge was ist das das ist ein wohnzimmer
was macht erika im wohnzimmer fred
rieger liegt auf der couch und liest ein
buch über west berlin
so macht man das also hier die ganze
zeit an diesem ort gibt es einen großen
esstisch kaffee und sehr viel schokolade
was ist das für ein ort helge das ist
ein esszimmer in der weihnachtszeit
jetzt verstehe ich warum es hier diese
ganze weihnachtsdekoration gibt immer
schön rot und gold alles wo sind wir
jetzt jetzt sind wir in der küche und
hier ist man frühstück mittagessen und
abendessen oder bereitet es zu das ist
eine offene küche
hier kann man kochen und sitzen und
essen und auch freunde haben wenn man
kocht können die freunde dort stehen und
gucken was man so alles schneidet und
zubereitet zeigt uns etwas typisch
deutsches in der küche
kritiker willst du vielleicht was zeigen
ja für mich ist es nutella
das habe ich das erste mal in
deutschland gegessen dass das darf in
bike einem frühstück fehlen
das ist so lecker alle deutschen essen
immer nur gezeigt für uns deinen
kühlschrank sehr gerne
ich zeig mal was ich hier drin habe also
ganz deutsch das allererste ist
natürlich ein bisschen bier hier sehr
lecker auch bayerisches bier hier ein
schönes lagerbier hell
augustina sehr zu empfehlen und dann
natürlich süße sind auch unwiderstehlich
und natürlich aber auch schafe sind und
dijon senf und schwedischer sind sind
sehr wichtig in diesem haushalt wo mein
test ihr senf oder wozu zu allem
möglichen zu tortellini aber auch zu
würstchen und immer wenn man nicht so
richtung kartoffeln heja guter punkt wir
haben natürlich auch kartoffeln hier und
sehr durch lecker lecker und natürlich
auch verschiedene käsesorten das mögen
wir auch so gern dieser kühlschrank ist
made in germany was ist das für ein raum
hängen
das ist dass gäste arbeitszimmer im
moment was ist ein gäste arbeitszimmer
müssen eure gäste hier arbeiten ja klar
nein janus das gästezimmer ist ein
zimmer mit zwei funktionen das ist ein
gästezimmer
aber wenn keine gäste da sind ist es ein
arbeitszimmer
na ja da hast du recht das war unsere
episode aus einer wohnung in berlin
wir bedanken uns bei helge amerika und
billiges vater der uns in seiner
abwesenheit in seine wohnung eingeladen
hat banken ja bitte das richtig auch
gerne aus
was macht ihr jetzt wir gehen jetzt in
ein griechisches restaurant griechisches
ist schwierig auszusprechen und ihr
könnt jetzt übungen machen bei petrol zu
dieser episode und hier könnt ihr sie
german abonnieren hast du auch easyjet
abonniert das habe ich mache erst jetzt